[Musique]
c'était il ya très très longtemps qu'on
ce temps là il y avait le ciel à droite
du ciel il y avait la planète jpy elle
était complètement plate et elle
penchait soit d'un côté soit de l'eau à
gauche du ciel il y avait la planète
shadoks
elle n'avait pas de forme spéciale au
plus tôt et le changer de sens au milieu
du ciel il y avait la terre qui était
ronde et qui bougeait sur la terre il
n'y avait apparemment sur la planète jib
il y avait des animaux qui s'appelait
jbe voici un jbe vu de près en voici un
autre quand il y avait trop de gy be d'à
côté la planète pencher les gy be glissé
il y en avait qui tombaient c'était très
gênant surtout pour les jbe sur la
planète shadoks
il y avait des shadoks de deux sortes
des shadoks avec des pieds en bas qui
vivait au dessus de la planète et des
shadoks avec des pieds au qui vivaient
de l'autre côté et qui servait à
soutenir la planète par en dessous
comme la planète j'adore changer de
forme il y avait des shadoks qui
tombaient c'était très gênant surtout
pour les shadoks
les shadoks élégie be on y ont donc
assez au bout d'un certain temps de
vivre sur deux planètes que ne marche
pas bien alors ils décidèrent les uns et
les autres d'aller sur la terre tous
avaient l'air de bien marcher
[Musique]